>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Sandra Charles: Good morning
and welcome to this lecture
on [inaudible] Telemedicine,
but with a whole lot
more girth to it.
We are pleased to have
Professor Auffret here from --
talking to us about
artificial intelligence
and we're hearing so much.
I get at least three or
four emails a day talking
about different aspects
both of AI and Telemedicine,
just all the different
terminology
and all the different ways
in which this is being used
in health services and in
aging services in particular.
So I was more than
happy to join Dr. Steen
and the Science Division in
bringing Professor Auffret here
and I know you're
in for a treat.
We'll be all so much more
edified when this is over
and be able to speak
about the whole topic.
And not only that, but we'll be
more encouraged and energized
to go do more research
or read more about it
because it's not a passing fad.
It is where we are and
where we are going.
So I will ask Dr. Steen
to introduce our speaker
and I'd say sit back and be
ready for a wonderful program.
Thank you so much.
I encourage you -- this is
actually a part of our Health
and Wellness Programming for
the month of May, and it's sort
of the opening lecture
which we always dedicate
to some aspect of
aging and health.
And then next door will
be the various providers
that you can ask questions
on a variety of things.
We have several area
hospitals participating as well
as individual pharmacies
and providers.
So we hope this day
will prove for you
to be much more energizing than
you've had in a while in terms
of thinking about
and taking care
of your health and wellness.
So thank you so much
for being here.
I failed to introduce
myself at the beginning.
For purposes of the program
I'm Dr. Sandra Charles,
Chief of the Health
Services Office
and also Chief Medical Officer
here at the Library of Congress.
Thank you again and welcome.
>> Thank you.
>> Tomoko Steen:
It's a great pleasure
to [inaudible] Professor
Auffret again.
I'm Tomoko Steen,
Science, Technology,
and Business Division of here
at the Library of Congress.
Professor Auffret last year
gave a very interesting talk
on cybersecurity.
And this was recorded, so,
you know, please let me know.
I'm happy to show you a URL
and you can watch the
talk as well [inaudible].
And we are so lucky to have
Professor Auffret twice,
and he is a Research Partnership
Director at School of Business
as well as he's Associate
Director for the Center
for Assurance Research
and Engineering
at the Engineering School.
So he has undergraduate
degree from Duke University.
He's A.B. Duke [inaudible]
and also MBA
from the University of Virginia.
And he's also PhD in Physics
from American University/
So he has just broad
range of background.
And he has been Director
for the MES Programs
at the George Mason University.
And also he's charity ranges
quite broad from CIO, ICT,
cybersecurity, so the team
explained what's CIO and ICT,
but it's so many, you know,
discussion right now
you're going to, you know,
[inaudible] our aging population
and this is a very
important topic.
So Professor Auffret
is also [inaudible]
for Healthy Information
Technology Advisory Committee,
and also worked with the
World Bank and variety
of important organizations
including World
Health Organization.
And also he was a
business executive
for the MCI and British Telecom.
He has also appointment
with Duke University Center
for International Development.
And he is a Physicist
in Residence
at American University.
So ICT. May be I just -- so many
people ask me about what ICT
when puts announcement.
It's Information and
Communication Technology.
And, you know, many countries
were facing such issues
of aging, how to
manage aging population.
So today's lecture is going to
review and analyze and status
in the potential of ICT for
healthcare in aging populations.
And it's a wonderful topic to
discuss and he has a broad range
of connection internationally
so that his topic is going
to cover America's,
Europe, Africa, and Asia.
So before [inaudible]
please join me
in welcoming Professor Auffret.
>> Jean-Pierre Auffret:
Thank you, Tomoko.
[ Applause ]
Where did my pen -- thank you.
Thank you all for joining
and thank you Dr. Charles.
As Tomoko said, the talk is
going to range from healthcare
to aging society to
technology to policies.
And policies help
introduce technologies
into a society for healthcare.
So it will be quite a broad
range, and I'm looking forward
to the discussion afterwards,
including from a special guest,
Yuki Memora [assumed spelling],
who's also very active
in the aging society topic
and hosting a Washington
Innovation Network here
in Washington.
So, welcome, Yuki.
Shoot. Just kind
of to review then,
going to have some
background on aging society
and the technology landscape,
some of the challenges
in what's actually needed to
spur innovation in the field,
and then a little look, short
look, at National ICT Policies
and National Aging
Policies and Strategies.
Before we start, I wanted
to play a short video.
Just have a couple of
these from Japan on some
of the introduction
of technology
into assisted living facilities.
So a range of experimentation
in Japan,
both with the rapidly aging
society looking to further care
for seniors but also
to be a world leader
in silver technologies,
to be able to export
these technologies
to other countries
around the world.
We'll play this short video
on some of the applications
at this one nursing home,
and I think it gives
a pretty good feel
for the range of possibilities.
[ Inaudible Conversations ]
>> This [inaudible] has an
unusual [inaudible] trainer.
[Inaudible] by a robot
named [inaudible].
It's one of many iconic
aids the staff uses,
including [inaudible] to help
care for it's elderly patients.
[Inaudible] reports, this
[inaudible] in Japan.
>> Japan's population
is rapidly aging
and it's workforce is shrinking.
So it's facing this new shortage
of nursing care workers to care
for a growing number of elderly.
And it's planning to turn to
robots to help fill this gap.
>> Following [inaudible]
Japan's population [inaudible].
There's been decades
of [inaudible] robots
as friendly and useful.
People seem [inaudible] they
think these are the human touch.
>> And science has
made a robotic bed
that splits in half and half.
Half of it turns
[inaudible] wheelchair.
Cyberdyne has made
an exoskeleton
that you can wear attached
to your lumbar area
that helps workers lift
like people from their beds.
And probably the cutest robot
is a robotic seal called
[inaudible], which is used in
[inaudible] and he can respond
to touch, speech, light.
>> Tokyo sees this as a
big business opportunity,
and companies have joined
them in investing million
of dollars in robot R&D.
But they're also eyeing
potentially a bigger prize,
sending these homegrown
robots overseas,
especially to other nations
with populations [inaudible].
>> Jean-Pierre Auffret: So as
you can see, a lot of potential
and possibility for robots
and technologies with seniors,
but also a range of issues
in regard to like innovation
and scaling and adoption
[inaudible] --
So as you could see, a lot
of potential and possibility
for robots and technologies
with seniors, but also a range
of issues in regard
to innovation
and scaling and adoption.
And we'll cover some of those
during the course of the talk.
Aging isn't just
limited to Asia Pacific.
It's a worldwide
phenomena, aging societies.
So many of the European
countries
across Asia Pacific including
Japan, Korea, Singapore, Taiwan,
China itself because of some of
their policies over the years,
some of the South American
countries like Argentina
and Chile, and some of the
Middle Eastern countries, too,
and North African countries
such as Algeria and Iran,
all aging quite rapidly.
And over the coming years
going to be approaching 25-30%
or even 40% in Japan's case,
of the population being
65 years and older.
So significance aside
all challenge,
and for many countries
the risk is
of becoming older before they
become developed or richer.
So for a country like
Japan or Korea or some
of the European ones which are
very successful economically,
have public health
infrastructure in place,
their much in better
circumstances for aging society
than a developing country that
doesn't have public health
yet or, indeed, has a
relatively low GDP as some
of the developing countries do.
We'll see in a little bit, too,
it's also a phenomenon in Africa
where some of the African
countries projected not
to have 40% of their
population, but up to 20%
of their population age 65
and older by the year 2050.
So aging oftentimes is depicted
as homogenous, or one view,
of what aging is or
what aging means.
But, really, aging
is quite varied.
Many seniors now and over
the years quite active well
into their 60s, 70s,
80s, and 90s --
active in society,
active working.
Other seniors, more and more,
are trying to age in place
and there's different policies
around the world for that --
to be able to stay living
in their homes longer
as a way to stay engaged.
But also too many seniors
do have fragility issues
and then some also
have memory issues.
So very broad range of
seniors and a very broad range
of technologies which are
applicable to each of the groups
or circumstances of the seniors.
And we'll also see that, how the
technologies are being tailored,
including fostered and
promoted by the U.S. Government
for different types or
circumstances of seniors.
One thing which is a
major challenge worldwide,
and we'll talk about some of
the other challenges of aging
in addition to health, is
this question of poverty.
Seniors oftentimes, and in many
countries, don't have pensions
or something has
happened to the pension
such as municipal bankruptcy,
or a country doesn't have
a pension system yet,
and when the senior's no longer
working then then don't have a
regular income.
One other thing which
is happening
in many countries is
a change of culture.
So many countries traditionally
have had a cultural support
system where the young care
for and support the parents
and the grandparents
and the elderly.
That is changing in
many countries now,
including in Asia Pacific
where sometimes the youth moves
to the larger cities,
but the seniors remain
in the rural areas, and there's
not the contact or support
that that might have
been in previous decades.
One other issue, too, is with
the rapidly aging society,
instead of having six or seven
or eight younger people
supporting the seniors
through pensions or care, in
some countries it's moving
to three to one or two to one,
two people in the workforce
supporting one senior person.
So the support system
may or may not be there
from country to country.
So aging varies across
the world, and aging, too,
varies across the U.S.
but by county and city.
Some counties and cities
much more older than others.
On this slide here, darker
blue is a higher percentage
of a county with a population
of age 65 and over including
with a disability,
so having both.
You can see many counties
have a bluer shade
and are older than others.
Oftentimes these
are in rural areas.
I grew up in Florida
which has an interesting
population dynamic.
It's both a very large senior
population but also quite young
and somewhat limited in
the middle over the years.
So you can see some of
these counties quite rural,
quite limited incomes.
With some of the healthcare
policy we've had or some
of the circumstances with
those rural hospitals closing
and support systems not being
what they might be, and so here,
too, in the United States, aging
can be a challenging issue.
One other note on
disparities in health.
There's the -- have many
of you heard about or read
about the stroke belt?
Also a major public
health issue.
So there's a band across
northern North Carolina,
southern Virginia going
across into Kentucky,
and the population there
has incidents of stroke
at a much earlier age and
much higher preponderance
than across the rest
of the country.
So it's a little bit unclear
as to the causes of that.
Some mix of probably
genetics and diet.
But there, too, there's
a disparity of incidents.
And we'll come back
to that when we talk
about fragility for seniors.
Here's another chart.
This one is population
over 65 by county.
So you see some of the very
popular retirement areas
in Palm Springs, also Florida,
but also quite varied
across the country.
Oftentimes younger
working-age move
to where economies
are more dynamic,
but true around the world.
But here, too, in the U.S.
Do quite a lot with APEC.
APEC, Asia-Pacific
Economic Cooperative,
a multilateral organization
of 21 or 23 countries
around the Asia Pacific
Region, and here, too,
you can see the vast differences
in percentage of aging.
And also vast differences
in type of economy and level
of development of economy.
So quite striking the
projection for year 2050,
the right-hand column.
Japan projected 42.5% of
the population 65 and older.
Korea, which has had
the lowest birthrate
for many years now, 41.5%.
Really quite interesting.
Thailand, a middle
income country, at 37.1.
So it really varies
across the world.
So impact on society and
social inclusion, productivity,
all those types of things
related to demographics.
These also quite
striking type of maps --
this is year 2000
on the upper map,
darker brown the code is
more aged like 25 or 30%
or over, 65 and older.
But the bottom map,
world map, is 2050.
And you can see that the shift
in colors over the years.
Not very many countries would
[inaudible] dark browns.
If you can bear with me in
2050 [inaudible] not others.
Oh, yes. Thank you.
[Inaudible] gave a talk
last year in Argentina.
It was partially related to
productivity in the workforce.
So Argentina, a middle
income country,
although with a somewhat sad
political history and sadly back
in the news again recently.
But here, too, you can see
that the shift in population
and the increasing number
of elderly, decreasing size
or stable size of the workforce.
So a challenge for Argentina
to increase productivity
to help address their debt
issues to be as dynamic
as they could be
with their economy.
And think this is the most --
really quite amazing chart
in regards to demographics.
So China with the highest
population in the world,
but not for very much longer.
So quite rapidly aging with the
one child policy over the years.
Relatively soon and
into the 2040s
and 2050s the India workforce
going to be much, much,
much larger than China.
So great ramifications
for China in regard
to competitiveness
and productivity.
I didn't bring any
charts on this, but China,
the most rapid adopter
in manufacturing,
one of, of robotics.
And partially it's to
remain competitive.
Partially, too, it's with --
in regard to their aging issue.
[ Inaudible Conversations ]
Okay. One of the challenges
I mentioned is the this issue
of workforce and productivity,
and we'll come back
to health in a second.
So the Korean population
somewhat flat
and will be declining a little
bit over the coming years
as their population ages.
Their productivity as a country
has been flat or decreasing.
They're of a size where it's
quite challenging economically,
so they're not as large
in population-wise
as a U.S. or a Japan.
They have about 50
million people.
So for Korea to maintain
competitiveness in the face
of a flat or declining
population is a great challenge
for them.
Also, too, they have structural
limitations from policies.
So the retirement age
is quite low in Korea.
They're working to develop
policies and approaches to --
so people can stay
in the workforce.
Traditionally what's happened
is someone will retire
from a very skilled
or skill-oriented job
and not really have anything
to move to that's comparable,
and might end up doing something
that is not taking
advantage of their talents.
So they're trying
to address that.
They're also trying
to address some
of the employment
challenges that they have.
They're dominated by the
very large conglomerates
such as the one Samsung is in.
Limited opportunity for youth.
And so there's an office
right here on Gallows Road.
It's related to the Korea U.S.
Science Technology Center.
But what it does is it enables
Korean companies the opportunity
to come here to the U.S. to
further their exports or look
to see if the U.S. is
a good market for them.
And then the Korean
government also has 14 offices
around the world for recent
Korean university graduates
to go overseas to get a couple
of years of university --
work experience before
coming back to Japan.
So Korea, in that middle
size, and it's going
to be quite a challenge as
that they -- the society ages.
Pensions, too, can be a
great challenge worldwide.
So some countries don't have
pension systems developed yet.
Others have quite robust pension
systems that are under-funded.
This was a news headline
from Stockton, California,
a number of years ago when
their city went bankrupt.
And so there was a risk
to both the pensions
of their former municipal
employees but also
that the healthcare benefit
that the city was
purchasing for retirees.
So pensions can be a
big, big, big challenge
and a big issue both for
developed and developing.
A couple of other notes on major
trends before we focus more
on the technology in healthcare
that are related to aging.
One is urbanization.
Many of the young move to the
outskirts of the larger cities
in developing countries,
the larger mega-cities.
Lagos, for example, has grown
from about 500,000 population
to about 20 million
over the course
of the last several decades,
so really rapid growth
in a country like Nigeria.
But many, many cities
around the world.
Countries struggle to provide
city services, provide jobs.
It's also -- help address
social inclusion issues.
And so with aging, it's
just adds to the challenge
or compounds the challenge.
One interesting phenomena
in Japan, very recently.
So Professor Obio
[assumed spelling],
a colleague of Yuki's.
Over many years, the youth
were moving to the cities
and the elderly were
staying in the rural areas.
Now more and more of the youth
are looking to the rural areas
for their livelihoods, and
there's been a little bit
of a pendulum shift in Japan but
with, I think, a lot of benefits
for a more heterogeneous
society in the rural areas.
Here's a slide showing
the recent change
of the preponderance of
population living in cities.
So, of course, here, it's been
many, many decades since --
the crossing point
is when the more
than 50% were living in cities.
So many, many decades here
and in Argentina and Europe.
But worldwide, only
fairly recently
that that the cities have become
the main hub of livelihood
in many, many countries.
And this also really
kind of interesting
from a map standpoint.
This is 1970.
Darker color brown is more
higher percentage urban.
And then this is 2030.
You can see many, many more
countries have a higher
percentage of urban living,
but also the red circles
are larger cities,
like over 10 million in size.
So big shift in how people
live and related to aging.
And then other big shift related
to aging is chronic illness.
So also only recently
was a shift --
that from worldwide mortality go
from the preponderance
being communicable diseases
to the preponderance
being chronic illness.
And so with aging -- with
seniors living longer,
and with improvements in
healthcare, more and more
of a challenge of
chronic illness.
But also this is true worldwide,
not just with seniors.
With chronic illness,
it's a much different type
of healthcare than with
communicable disease,
much more focus on
continuity of fit care,
engaging of allied health,
role of diet, role of adherence
to medical recommendations,
and a much more important role
of health literacy on the
part of the population.
To show that it's quite
international, India,
for example, has a very high
like occurrence of diabetes,
one of the highest in the world.
And interestingly enough, the
higher occurrence in the world
of Hepatitis C is Egypt.
And it came about from
a public health failure.
The Egyptian Government was --
they had a parasitic Nile River
disease, and they were trying
to inoculate the population
against this in the '60s,
but they were using
dirty needles.
And so now they have a really
major Hepatitis C incidence
in Egypt.
But there, too, chronic
illness being a worldwide issue.
And here -- this was a diabetes.
And you can see darker green is
higher incidents of diabetes.
So Mexico, Libya, Saudi,
Arabia, India, fairly high.
Quite varied around
the world of that.
Okay. So what's happening in
technology that's really a plus
or an opportunity for
healthcare and for seniors
and for staying connected and
for living, aging in place,
and living longer, and more
engaged in active lives.
A lot of it has to do with the
mobile phone and with sensors,
as with a lot in our society.
So the advances have
been quite remarkable,
and the opportunity
quite remarkable, too,
for really connecting
people with services
that they didn't have
access to before.
So just in 2015, already
7 billion mobile phone
subscribers, more than one for
every person on the planet.
And it's not just
-- it's worldwide.
It's developing countries
and developed.
A little bit less
so in rural areas,
and a little bit less
so in some countries.
But these mobile
phones with the power
of computers providing services
that weren't really forecastable
10 or 15 or 20 years.
Also, too, this -- the more
and more increasing number
of connected devices
and sensors as we'll see
for assisted technology
really providing capability
that wasn't there before in
the whole mobile app inroads.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
One kind of note which I
think is neat in regard
to how rapidly technology
changes and how it's difficult
to forecast where it may
be in 10 or 20 years --
these are just pictures,
but -- of status storage,
transmission speed,
and processing power.
But just to show how far
we've come, the first one --
so say you can go
into a computer store
and buy a several
terabyte storage like near
where I live, where we live.
It's like 30 or $40 or $50
for like three terabytes,
and it's the size of a book.
The first commercially available
gigabyte storage was just 1980,
so not that long ago in many
ways, and it was 550 pounds,
the size of a refrigerator,
and cost $40,000.
And it was marketed by IBM.
So from this and one gigabyte
of $40,000 to about this
for multiple terabytes from
$50 has been the change.
And so that change
is continuing.
And so the underlying cost of
storage, the variable cost,
is going to be almost
zero shortly.
The processing speeds similarly.
So now it's six, seven, or
eight going in cycles a second
in a computer on research.
Kind of a coincidence --
the first lunar lander and also
the first Apple computer were
both 2000 cycles a second.
So from 1970 to today,
from 2000 to 8 billion,
and that's advancing, too.
And then the transmission speed
-- the first transatlantic cable
from 1957 could only handle
about 36 simultaneous calls.
And now it's billions
and billions of calls
on a fiberoptic network.
So with those trends continuing,
just as you couldn't really
foresee the capability
of the iPhone if you
were back in 1990,
you can't really foresee
what the computers
or the phones will
be doing in 2025.
You have an idea of what the
applications might be in regard
to [inaudible] with cars
and sensors or with videos
and images and holograms,
but the specific
applications you can't really --
it's hard to visualize.
This is a neat resource that
comes out every fall from ITU,
a Measuring Information Society.
The blue line that's going
up towards 100% is mobile
phone subscriptions,
so about 100 mobile phone
subscriptions per 100 people
around the world.
The really dark blue one that's
quite steep on the right --
that's mobile broadband
subscriptions.
And you can see that's
increasing more rapidly
than mobile phone, so probably
in several years we'll be
up to 70, 80, 90 mobile
broadband subscriptions per 100
population around
the world, developed
and developing countries.
So great, great, great change.
And this, too, I think
is another background
on what's possible,
what technology.
For Mexico's to the left, shows
the percentage of the population
in Mexico that is banked
or has bank accounts.
The right shows the percentage
of the population
with a mobile phone.
So much, much, much higher.
So Mexico, one of the countries
where these types of apps,
where you can do banking through
the phone like M-Pesa in Kenya,
really making inroads.
So instead of having traditional
bank accounts, going to one
of these phone-based
bank systems
and really providing access.
And so -- also for health, too.
Of course, the whole smart
city playing a big role
in aging society as we'll talk
about as well as the smart grid,
so really changes in how
electricity is provided.
I didn't include a slide,
but Africa, for example,
just in the last 20 years and
projected out to 2020 the amount
of power which has
been brought online,
and related to the phones,
or enabling the phones,
has really led to major shifts.
One other video I want to
play before we talk more
about health is not
all technology has
to be really leading edge.
And it's possible to do things
in health with technology
that is somewhat
dated such as SMS.
And there's some
wonderful examples
around the world
including here in the U.S.
of using SMS-type technology to
really further health outcomes
and benefit seniors in a
way just as much as some
of the more advanced
robotic or AI technologies.
So this is a really neat
initiative in Tanzania
with Novartis and IBM.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
[ Music ]
So the idea is that
the mortality
from malaria is very high
for children under the age
of five without treatment.
And Tanzania there having
very, very high incidence
of malarial medicine
stock-outs in rural clinics.
And so with Novartis and IBM
and a telecom [inaudible]
developed a system
where the clinician would
just send a text message
in once a week on
her inventory level.
And if the inventory was
low or nearing a stock-out,
it would be replenished.
And they went from 80% or
so stock-outs to a very,
very small number with
the corresponding benefit
for the children and
for children's health.
There's a number of amazing
examples similar to this.
Pharmaceutical counterfeiting
is rampant in some countries.
And an almost similar
system in one or two
of the West African countries
is you don't buy the medicines
from a pharmacy like
we do here, like a CVS.
It's more from a small shop.
But just a code on the side of
the medicine that you can type
into your -- send a text
message with your phone
and it validates
it that it's real.
So here we have a new law that's
going to take effect early 2020s
on a pharmaceutical
traceability.
And the -- what the legislation
calls for is the ability
to trace a pharmaceutical all
the way from manufacturing plant
to when we actually pick
it up at the pharmacy.
And so much more advanced
than this text message idea.
But some of the pharmaceutical
companies are looking
at block chain for
that, for example.
Okay. So technology doesn't need
to be advanced, but, of course,
a lot of the technologies are
advanced including with robotics
with a lot of promise for
seniors but a lot of promise
for society and a
lot of risk also.
The Asian Development Bank
puts out an annual report
in the spring, and it
just came out this year.
And they have a fascinating
chapter on the job impact
in developing Asia
countries from robotics.
It was quite a, I thought,
sophisticated study
because they had the downside
risk industry by industry,
from country to country.
They also had the
upside potential
of access to the job markets.
And then they also
looked at a forecasting
when robotics would
be adopted industry
by industry based upon the cost,
the economic opportunity as well
as the technological capability.
But many robots used for
different applications.
The one on the bottom right
is an English-speaking robot
in Korea which is
really a popular teacher.
The upper left is the
more traditional view
of industrial robots.
But you can see by
comparing the two,
that the robots are
quite different.
So robots are becoming
more non-tethered.
But the one on the left is
tethered and stationary.
More mobile and non-tethered,
more autonomous
and more interactive
and in some ways more
"intelligent," in quotes.
So through all of that,
much greater interaction
with humans and individuals.
And so many more risks
for the individual.
Many more societal implications
and public policy implications
as these larger and faster
robots are interacting
on a day-to-day basis.
So there's a lot of studies
which are really quite
interesting on the use of robots
and humans together
as to whether
or not a human plus a robot has
greater capability than a human
on its own or a robot
on its own.
In one of the studies which gets
quoted a lot is a chess study.
So pairing -- this is
from several years ago --
pairing the chess-playing
programs that the real top ones
and the not quite top ones
-- with chess-playing humans,
really, really top ones
and not so top ones.
And the winning teams from
the experiment were --
it wasn't that the best human
or the best robot or AI.
It was the one that
worked best together.
And you can see that's going
to be a factor in many fields.
So, for example,
medical diagnosis --
the IBM Watson does
commercials quite --
or commercials about
Watson quite often.
Doctors are using Watson at
Cleveland Clinic I believe.
But there it's an interaction
of what the AI tells the doctor
and what the doctor
interprets and what the --
what information that the
Artificial Intelligence provides
to the doctor so the
doctor can make a judgment
over how accurate it is.
One kind of aside on that.
It's a major, major
issue that this question
of artificial intelligence
and transparency.
Here in the U.S.,
but also in Europe,
and there's a really
interesting case with Zillow.
Does anyone follow that case?
So many of you probably
use Zillow or seen it.
So Zillow is a home
and condominium site.
And one of the things
it has on there in order
to draw traffic is
it has an algorithm
that generates what a house
is worth or valued or would go
for on the open market today.
And so you can go on there
any day and type in a property
or your own address and
see what it's valued at.
It also has a chart for
historical estimates as well
as for the neighborhood.
And so an attorney saw that
her house was being undervalued
on Zillow, a very, very nice
house, high-priced house,
and it was hindering
her ability to sell it.
And so she sued Zillow and
-- but Zillow didn't --
and so the judge wanted
to see how Zillow operated
and how Zillow came
up with the estimate
of what the house was worth.
But Zillow said it was a trade
secret, how it was doing it.
So the judge had to make
arrangements to hire an expert,
but the plaintiffs paid,
to review the system
in order to make a judgment.
So that works in the cases when
it's an algorithm or can work,
but in these issues --
circumstances with machine
learning that the AR
or the machine gathers
information from the Internet
and then slowly over time
develops an insight and a view.
It's much harder,
if not impossible,
to know how the machine came
up with its recommendation
or solution.
But the laws now in Europe
-- there's a transparency law
and algorithms that
you have to be able
to show how a computer
arrived at a decision.
And also, too, that there's
laws so that someone can ask
for a human to make a
choice instead of a machine.
So as an example, a university
hypothetically could use a
computer to decide who's
admitted, really quite possible.
And some jurisdictions have
experimented with computers
as to whether or not someone
should be paroled or whether
or not they'll be at
risk if they're paroled.
So the -- a lot of the policy
orientation is what recourse
does an individual have because
you can't really depose the
computer necessarily, and
then so what recourse is,
and how do you know
how it made its choice?
And then what can you
really do about it?
Or even, for example,
if a autonomous vehicle caused
an accident when you go --
and if someone was going to
sue the insurance company,
you can't really depose it, or
how do you find out about it?
This is actually in
interesting picture, too.
So this is an assisted
robot for Japan.
So with a rapidly aging society,
limitations on the number
of health workers to assist --
so this one to help lift someone
out of a bed and move
from one bed to another
or when a bed is being made.
You can imagine the legal
risk on something like that.
As it turns out in the
U.S. that there are --
every year there's an
incidence of people being,
patients being dropped
in hospitals, too.
So -- but that one
being adopted in Japan.
And I think we would
see something
like that here over time also.
One of the arguments from the
autonomous vehicle providers is
that the autonomous vehicle will
be safer than a human driver.
But that's not the view
of all the car companies.
Toyota, for example,
their view is more
that the autonomy is assistive.
And so there's a range of
circumstances where visibility
and rain, when the
autonomy is really helpful.
But not at all times
necessarily.
This is a very famous
Japanese robot,
Chihira Kanae, from Toshiba.
One thing to note
is Japan's going
to be really highlighting robots
for the 2020 Olympics,
including at Narita.
But there's different
cultural views
of what a robot should
look like.
So, in Japan they have the video
reference Paro for the autism
and aging, a very cute
and attractive seal.
This robot looks
much, much different.
So this one looks as if a human.
So there's cultural
differences on that.
So I think in the U.S., this
is a broad generalization,
but for the most part,
our robots are idealized
to some extent, and
less human looking.
But some countries,
they do have robots
that are a little bit
more human looking.
So, again, cultural
differences in robots.
Here's a initiative here
from the U.S., from HHS.
Research -- I think
this was from last year,
the announcement request
for proposal for robotics
with Alzheimer's assistance.
So many, many opportunities
for research grants in --
at the end here, I'll discuss
a little bit how our government
tries to catalyze research.
I have to be very
cognizant of the time.
Two other areas which the great
[inaudible] impact for seniors,
nonhealthcare, is one
is autonomous vehicles.
This is actually
a drone in Rwanda.
So Rwanda's very hilly.
And so this commercial company
to deliver fixed-wing drone,
deliver medicines to rural areas
because the roads aren't
necessarily that good.
And they do deliveries
within two or three hours.
They can get their order
in and ship it out.
But the point more in general
is that autonomous vehicles,
especially for seniors
living in rural areas
where they've lost
the bus routes,
which happens all
over the world.
Now with autonomous
vehicles there's a way
where the senior could
actually have a vehicle
that can bring them into town
or they'd be much more mobile
and more able to live
and age in place.
This is just kind of -- this
is a autonomous drone in Dubai.
I don't think I would get into
one like that, but that's there.
And then, too, the artificial
intelligence becoming much
more flexible.
So chess, although very
complex and complicated,
somewhat limited in regard
to its one application.
But more and more some of the AI
applications are quite flexible
as to what they're doing
and quite large ramifications,
I think, for society.
We use AI every day, most
every one of us, in some ways.
So, for example, someone
going shopping on Amazon,
and the recommendations
that come from Amazon,
sometimes they're a
little bit creepy I think,
the types of things
that they do.
But a lot of that is from
AI and gathering information
about a person and then
utilizing it in a way
to [inaudible] back
a recommendation.
There's a projection
for Philippines
that in the next two years
they're going to lose 30%
of their call center employees.
So Philippines, a major
industry with call centers.
So you call from here
and you get someone
from Philippines quite often.
So a lot of the first and
second level that the levels
with not the huge expertise,
the projection is they're going
to be replaced by automated
assistants in the next years.
So a very, very big
issue for Philippines
with job replacement and AI.
And then the last thing
[inaudible] trend, I think,
is this open data issue that
the data being available
and the potential both for
benefit for seniors but also
for society in building
businesses.
So here in our area we have
a quite robust open data,
the federal government
obviously,
the counties, New York, too.
Some of the really neat
applications I think is what you
can do with trending
over time for seniors.
There's a really neat
company here locally.
It's now possible to get from --
a [inaudible] from HHS much
more quickly than years ago,
information on Medicare and
Medicaid payments and care.
And it's six months
or probably less now.
And so local company here
obtains the information
from HHS, then they're able
to do comparisons from region
to region or from hospital
system to hospital system
and provide the information back
out to enable the caregivers
to hopefully provide
better care.
Okay. So how is technology
actually being used for aging?
And it really varies
by the type of --
where the senior is in aging.
So again in place,
an active aging type
of technology may
well be in exercise
or an autonomous vehicle.
Someone who's a little bit
more fragile might be assisted
for mobility or for sight
or with chronic illness.
Then, too, for memory care,
such as with the Paro
from Japan, the seal.
So aging very, very,
very different.
And then also the
government services vary too.
The one on the right
from New Jersey I think,
a really important type of
initiative in times of emergency
to know where the seniors
are, to know where the ones
who have memory issues are so
you're able to better evacuate.
So it's a huge impact
and benefit both
to the senior themselves
and to the city if you know
where everyone in your city
is who needs an oxygen tank
in regard -- if the
power goes off.
So those types of things
are big, big benefit.
One of the things
I think that --
really quite important in aging
is this concept of fragility.
There's probably 80 different
models of how to define it now.
But fragility both of movement,
but also fragility of health --
inability to take a number of
stresses to a person's system.
So someone very young
in their 20s,
they can take multiple
health stresses and be fine.
But someone older is
much, much more difficult.
Fascinating study
from Japan on seniors.
And this is with
fragility in movement.
It's very, very -- their study
found that it's very difficult
if you move from quite active
to limited mobility and fragile
in movement, and then almost
non-mobility to go back,
to make your way back
from very limited --
almost no mobility to
fragile and fragile to active.
So a lot of the interventions
are to --
if someone is to prevent
someone or help someone
so they don't move
to the next stage.
And there's also models like
this for cognitive fragility
and the intersections
of the two,
more physical and
more confident.
But a lot of the technologies
are oriented towards this type
of idea that to help someone
stay in an earlier stage,
a more healthy stage,
and help them move back
or to the extent it's
possible as they move further.
Because everyone knows someone
who's gone ill when they're
in their 70s or 80s, and it's
much more difficult recovery,
much more challenging or a
fall is much more challenging.
This is a similar model for WHO
on functioning and disability.
It's quite a similar idea,
but here it's the degree
of societal participation and
then functioning, physical
and mental functioning in
the intersection of the two.
So the point being
there's a great benefit
from engaging societally
or with family and a risk
from social inclusion.
And so -- and also a benefit
from some physical activity.
So what are some of
the technologies?
This is really a quite
neat one I think.
And this is an [inaudible].
Canada has, and Taiwan and New
Zealand is actually a leader
in this, have implemented these
fairly widely in some cities.
So enabling the phone
or the cane
with communications
technologies to connect
to beacons or sensors.
So a lot of the sight-impaired
now have GPS on the phone
that can direct them to a
place where there's GPS.
But if in a very large
building or a subway station,
they don't have the GPS.
But to put beacons in there
and to communicate back
with the cane or the phone or
the eyeglasses as in Canada,
and really help someone
there with their mobility
and their confidence
to get around.
And it can be really
very, very lifechanging.
There's a video, which
I'm not going to show,
of someone about 30 years
old who -- in Canada --
who lost their sight
through diabetes.
And she now has these types of
technologies and is really able
to get around and do quite well.
So a wonderful lady
at NIH who also --
who lost her sight
when she was about 25
and she afterwards moved --
started in information
technology and, again,
is able to do tremendously with
the assistance of technologies.
This is a second one,
cognitive ability,
which a lot of technology's
very helpful with.
Both continuing with -- to
be engaged, but also some
of the technologies more and
more able to identify trends
and patterns for
early intervention.
For example, with
dementia or Alzheimer's.
So I think with a lot
that's being done nowadays,
a lot of potential.
One thing that's
kind of interesting.
A George Mason professor I
work with has worked on this.
The way someone uses their
Smartphone is very unique.
You can identify someone
from the Smartphone usage.
So, of course, the intelligence
agencies are very interested
in that sort of thing.
But also, too, there's a thought
that over time someone
might have a change
in Smartphone pattern usage,
how they actually type
on the Smartphone.
And you can identify
insipient dementia from that.
So there's a number of
projects like that both here
and the U.S. but
around the world.
This is a DARPA Drive
technology.
Really tremendous
potential for seniors
for mobility and staying active.
This is an exoskeleton.
But many, many different
ways of doing this.
There's a number of
technologies that haven't worked
yet that I think are really
interesting if they could work.
Types of technologies that a
senior could wear, very light,
that would expand, for example,
on a fall to make it less likely
that a fall would
be catastrophic.
You're tied with sensors so
you might have an iPhone.
This is a local company
here in Fairfax
which is really kind
of remarkable.
So they have this -- the EyeGaze
Technology has come a long way.
At Consumer Electronics
Show they had an exhibit,
a company on exhibit this year
where you could drive a car just
by moving your eyes
and steer it.
This company here -- this is
for someone who's had a
really catastrophic accident
and is paralyzed from neck
down -- that they can --
someone can actually type and
write by moving their eyes
on this keyboard on this screen.
And when they come -- and we've
had several assisted technology
conferences, and the company
comes and gives a demo,
and some of their customers
come with stacks of books
that they've written
using this technology.
So it's for someone in
that sad circumstance.
It's really lifesaving.
It gives them a real path to
life I think, in livelihood.
A lot of the senior
technology --
this is for [inaudible] you
know, profession soccer players,
but we [inaudible] this as
senior technology with sensors.
So this technology here,
which is being adapted,
is having a communications
device in the soccer ball
and having sensors around
the stadium, and then also
on each player having a
communications device.
So you're able to track the ball
and all the players
in real time.
And then make judgments
about how they're playing
and how often they
have to have the ball.
So their golf technology --
if you ever watch gold
on T.V. they have --
they can actually track the
speed of the ball off the club,
and they do it with baseball
now, too, and follow the path.
But this having a big impact.
And then lastly, too, on
chronic disease management,
this is a Google
initiative for diabetes.
So being able to tell
insulin levels from tears
with a contact lens,
communicating either to a phone
or to a SmartGlass, and then
being able to provide a warning
if the insulin levels are --
or the patients are outside
of some sort of control
and that's -- so better care and
more stability of blood levels.
So, again, a neat thing that
technology's making possible.
So to wrap up, what are
some of the major challenges
of getting these types of
technologies to seniors
and to patients in general?
What is the phone coverage
and digital divide?
So even though there's almost
one phone per worldwide
inhabitant, in some areas the
phone coverage can be a little
bit iffy, the broadband
coverage.
And so that can be a
major, major issue.
Health literacy could be a
major issue and challenge, too.
I think this goes
both ways though.
So there's -- health
literacy is important
for using the technology
but the technology can help
with health literacy.
There's a Georgetown company
right there by the canal
and they were -- they provide
through Smartphones
text messages
to low income expectant
mothers, about-to-be mothers.
And their service was
highlighted by President Obama
and they're in many
hospitals nowadays with this,
and they've had -- they were
able to demonstrate a benefit
for both maternal
health and infant health.
So the messages are
coming from pediatricians,
so they're real healthcare
providers.
But they're able to
demonstrate that type of benefit
through the technology,
and it's measurable.
Doctor engagement also, too.
This varies by culture.
So in many or most countries'
cultures there's a hierarchy
that a doctor, being quite --
very, very well respected,
obviously.
But the technology changes
the dynamic a little bit.
And it changes it
differently country by country.
So in some countries the
patient's very empowered
and the doctors don't
necessarily like that.
In some other instances,
the technology
and the information
the patient has may
or may may not be
all that helpful.
One thing that's very much
in the news is electronic
medical records
in patient reporting,
and to what degree patient
reporting is helpful
to a doctor.
And some of the better
electronic medical records flag
the provenance of the
data as to whether it's
from a real healthcare
provider or from the patient.
And one also interesting
aspect of that is there's more
and more consumer
technology that people wear
like Pit Bitz and things.
Many, many, which are
quite high quality.
So the information is 7 by 24
as opposed to clinical trials
where you go to the hospital
once a week and you're tested.
And so there's a couple
of clinical trials --
one at Duke and one
at Stanford --
to use commercially-available
technology with 7
by 24 information
and then seeing
if you can make a judgement on
a new other device or treatment.
Some of the other
issues -- I'll skip some.
Obviously payer models.
Reimbursement really,
really important
for any technology
to be adopted.
Here in the U.S., our
laws changed last year.
So, historically,
for telemedicine --
for telemedicine to be
reimbursed you have to be
in a medically underserved area
which was most often a rural
area, or a city, a very,
very urban inner-city-type area.
But it changed last year, so
it's much more reimbursable now
to -- - - for -- to --
back to the insurers.
And also more -- Medicare and
Medicaid more open to paying.
Standards, obviously,
interoperability.
Market size has to have
a financial benefit
to private sector companies.
And then adoptability.
Some companies and some
research projects are fantastic
at engaging seniors and
engaging the patients in design.
Others not so.
I think that's true
with IT in general.
Some of the IT development
projects are fantastic
in engaging users in advance.
And then others not so
much oriented that way,
and the system is finished
and might not be all
that fit for a purpose.
So engaging the users
is very important.
I'll wrap up in a second.
This dual use idea is really
quite interesting, too.
A lot of commercial --
military technologies are being
repurposed for aging
and for assistive needs.
Some of the hand motion
technologies being adapted
for autism and autistic
children.
Another need autism technology
-- this is local also.
For a severely autistic child
they have 20 or 30 caregivers,
so they have -- well,
the parents, obviously.
And then they have
psychologists,
they have language therapists,
they have their teachers
in the schools.
So many physical therapists
and many, many, many.
And as they go through
the course of the day,
periodically a child like that
might have a emotional incident
or outburst.
But they're somewhat
predictable and the technology
with this company
here locally --
they try to connect the
caregivers in the chain,
and if an early-morning
caregiver sees a sign,
they'll flag it to the next ones
so that they can react to --
interact with the child
differently based upon how the
child's day is going.
So again, just phone
technology but kind of neat.
And lastly, policy is
very, very important.
Most countries now have
national ICT policies.
And then most have
also ageing policies.
It's the rare country where
there's an intersection
of the two, where
there's a connectedness
of the ageing and ICT.
But tremendous potential.
Japan is connected there.
Theirs is quite well.
But others are working on it.
And then one last note here in
the U.S. I think one of the --
two of the best things we do
from a technology standpoint.
One is the small business
innovation research grant
program which was
the Alzheimer's
and robotics grant
was under that,
for fostering commercialization
of technologies
through small businesses.
It's a world leader.
Many countries are
trying to adapt it
to varying degrees of success.
But a small company with an idea
or somebody with a prototype
in an area of interest to the
government, there's quite a bit
of funding both to develop
it to a trial and then
to actually commercialize it.
And another good, really
good thing we do, I think,
from a research standpoint
is DARPA.
We do many good things.
But DARPA has been
very successful.
So a lot of the autonomous
vehicles technologies today
and around the world and here,
many companies working on it.
It started at DARPA
only about 12 years ago
with a DARPA Grand
Challenge for teams to come
and develop an autonomous
vehicle that was able to drive
through the Mojave Desert
for 108 miles along cliffs
and over hills and
everything like that.
In the first year, the
winning team [inaudible] went
eight miles.
And then all of them
had crashed by then.
And so, just a number
of years later,
this technology really
being adapted worldwide.
And so the DARPA
idea was two-fold.
But they had a lot, there
were a lot of initiatives
on the different
elements of a car.
But there weren't initiatives
to integrate them all together.
And that the autonomous vehicles
back then weren't military grade
and couldn't go 35
or 40 miles an hour.
And their view was, there
weren't enough research teams
or experts in the U.S. and
by developing this challenge,
that they foster
interest in this
and greatly increase the
number of research teams.
And so, in more recent DARPA
challenges has been robotics the
last several years.
And so the first one, 2013
and '15, the robots were --
they bounded it for robots
in natural disasters
like nuclear relief.
But the first year that the
robots were very limited
and couldn't go upstairs
or couldn't really do much.
And just in a few years,
a lot of the technology rapidly
advancing and cost is going
to be coming down and much
more available to people.
So with that, thank you
very much for coming.
It's a fascinating area and
an ageing society has many,
many needs and especially
with the intersection
of ageing society
and disability.
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Sandra Charles:
Thank you for this.
>> Jean-Pierre Auffret:
Oh, thank you.
>> Sandra Charles: That was most
fascinating and informative.
>> Jean-Pierre Auffret:
Oh, thank you.
>> Sandra Charles: Are there
questions for Dr. Auffret?
>> My name is [Inaudible].
Thank you for [inaudible]
subject wide-ranging,
still very concentrated,
interesting as well
as educational insight
on the subject.
Your presentation, very
[inaudible] to look
at several other aspects.
One of it then is
entrepreneurship.
How entrepreneurship
could provide [inaudible]
in this sense.
We, my group [inaudible] work at
the sound [inaudible] last year.
We were [inaudible].
With regards to that, look
at how the [inaudible]
could be entrepreneurial.
It could be not [inaudible]
more opportunities.
I just wonder how you look at
a [inaudible] rather than kind
of the receiver of the
technology as a senior citizen.
>> Jean-Pierre Auffret: Well,
I think it's a very neat
question because I think of --
>> Sandra Charles:
Could you [inaudible]?
>> Jean-Pierre Auffret:
Oh, but the -- thank you.
[Inaudible] that the question
is about the potential
for senior entrepreneurs
developing technologies
in addition to just being users.
I think with increasing
life expectancies
that many seniors
retire at 60 or 65 or 70
and will live to 90 or 95.
So they have years for a
full career ahead of them.
And those that are able to
remain active and vibrant
and healthy, really would also
benefit from an avenue or a path
and have a tremendous
amount to offer
and a tremendous
amount of insight.
So I think that there's many
senior entrepreneurs and I think
that the potential
is really great.
And they also would
bring insight
to these types of technologies.
But that the pensions
too, I think,
in social security also
probably to some extent,
what was designed when life
expectancies were much less
than today.
And so with seniors living,
population living so much
to much greater ages, potential
for second and third careers.
On one other note, I think it
does relate to the whole idea
of careers is somewhat
different now.
Much less of it in the U.S.
but many countries too,
where someone works for one
company for many, many years
and also with the way
technology changes so quickly.
Industries seem to
come and go also.
And so most people,
through the course
of their lives even before 65,
have three or four careers.
So a really excellent question.
>> Sandra Charles: Any others?
>> Jean-Pierre Auffret: Okay.
Well, thank you all for coming.
>> Sandra Charles: Thank you
very much again [applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.